My favorite President Obama moment was when he was elected President in 2008,...
...because in 2008 was when I was born.
I never cried before from an election result.
I don't know, just the magic of that moment,...
...of that man who we'd all been on this journey with,...
...take that stage with his family.
I was sitting at home in my living room...
...and I felt like I was a part of that crowd in that park.
I didn't think I would live to see an African-American emerge as President, but he did.
Third grade, when we had this project to write a letter to the White House.
It was really strange when he actually replied back because it was like,...
"Whoa, I'm a third grader and I can actually get a response from the President."
"I can actually make a difference."
In the aftermath of the school shootings in Connecticut,...
I don't know how he did it.
At one point, at the lectern, he started to sing "Amazing Grace,"
...and the entire congregation stood up and did the same.
And to me, it was just a powerful moment,...
...and one that the nation needed and one that he was able to provide.
His battle towards the end to pardon a lot of convicted felons...
...who had been given heavy sentences for small, drug-related crimes.
One part I remember most about the visit was how excited everybody in my house was....
...and especially all the young people who were helping us.
And I think the way they got so excited and so happy about it...
...was something that I would always remember.